i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
welcome everybody it is so great to be
back here today we have so much to talk
about first let me explain what happened
last week now understandably
last week i was gone and understandably
many people assumed
reasonably so
that this was part of my paternity leave
me being gone last week
it was not i was
suddenly in an emergency fashion
temporarily a single dad last week and
ended up having to bail on the entire
week uh let me tell you what's going on
so as many of you know
had a baby uh some weeks ago and took
about 10 days off initially and then
slowly kind of worked back into doing
the show but limiting my other stuff
with the idea that
once the baby is in age in a couple
months where she's no longer sleeping
all day then i would take some other
time off and and whatever but in the
meantime wanted to get back to hosting
and just kind of a little bit of a sense
of normality and last sunday night i was
ready to wake up monday and do the show
when at uh 3 a.m
my girlfriend wakes me up and says um
sir i'm not feeling well she doesn't
really call me sir but okay she said i'm
not feeling well um can we take my blood
pressure with um postpartum moms you
monitor for something called postpartum
preeclampsia and one of the signs of
that is high blood pressure and uh we
take her blood pressure this is 3am take
her blood pressure
blood pressure's fine
305 she says i'm i'm just really like my
abdomen just hurts i'm not feeling well
and we're thinking that's weird all
right let's let's call the ob the
obstetrician their on-call line and see
what they say
by 3 10 in the morning she's really not
feeling well and by 3 15
she's doubled over on our couch
and um at this point i'm saying what
what is this this this doesn't seem good
um my girlfriend has a really high pain
tolerance normally like during the
during the birth she asked you know when
would people normally start like getting
anesthesia and the nurses said oh 24
hours ago most people would have had
anesthesia she was like this really
isn't that bad so when she's doubled
over i know something something bad is
going on
uh by by 3 20 in the morning she says
you got to call 9-1-1 and at this point
i know it's bad i call 9-1-1 um and she
is just
in such abdominal pain that she's unable
to move 3 30 in the morning ambulance
shows up
and she's rushed to the hospital and
says
take care of the baby
so all of a sudden i am saying
i got to make formula uh i need to
figure out what's going on long story
short by about 11 in the morning about
eight hours into the er stay
um they figure out that she has
a um duodenum perforation the duodenum
is
sort of like between it's below the
stomach but above the next thing i guess
it would be like the small intestine i
think there's a perforation there and
we're thinking what what are the odds
young woman
healthy
all of a sudden a perforation that it's
just so unlikely
and what we find out and of course with
these things you never know a hundred
percent but what the surgeon and the ob
what everybody agreed upon is
this is a rare but known side effect
of a significant use of ibuprofen
ibuprofen well why
after the c-section she was put on
ibuprofen both in the hospital and then
after the fact every six hours that's a
lot of ibuprofen and this is sometimes
you get an ulcer from ibuprofen use you
can have gastritis and every once in a
while
you get a perforation
and this was that rare case this it's a
really serious condition there sometimes
uh
postpartum perforations
in other countries in different
situations lead to death
and so um she was rushed into surgery
it's a relatively simple surgery but
with very kind of intense complicated uh
recovery including not being able to eat
or drink anything for five days which is
a form of psychological torture so
that's why i was gone last week i was
going between the hospital
and um uh taking care of a baby
initially by myself and eventually we
got help from family and it was crazy i
mean i don't you know there's a million
different details i could give you about
uh how
how hot difficult situations are in
hospitals even in good hospitals
and um
you know also the realization of like
how do single moms do it you know when
we just randomly hear
oh barack obama was raised by a single
mom oh all right like
the day-to-day of that you know once you
get down to the logistics once you get
down to the specifics of what that is
it's incredible it it really is
and um i was always a supporter of all
you know funding and and programs to
help parents in general and single
parents and all i am doubly or tripoli
now a supporter after having experienced
it
um for a week particularly knowing very
little about babies i have to say
so
fortunately now
everybody's on the mend it is like a
four to six week recovery period in
total
but uh things have gotten much much
better
and everybody's reunited i'm no longer
doing the single dad thing but um and by
the way the other thing
single parents who work i mean this was
a this was a particularly acute
situation right where my girlfriend's in
the hospital and i'm home with a baby
and etc but
there
there's no way i could have worked i
mean it's just impossible right i was
doing the pediatrician appointments
managing the feeding
coordinating help with the family that
was able to help but you
there it was it's literally 24 7.
um and uh
i just i just don't even know i i don't
even know how i could have possibly done
any job and i'm lucky enough to have a
job where i'm the boss and i can say
well i'm off for the week and of course
we had we had great villains we had luke
beasley and we had pat and we had farron
and we had the resources to do that but
imagine that number one i had an
employer saying you know we start at 9
15 where are you and it's like oh i i
can't make it for a week
i can barely leave
the one room in my house where i'm doing
things um but imagine also that i
my income went to zero as a result of
that as many people don't have paid time
off
uh or sick time or whatever the case may
be so
incredibly eye-opening and horrifying
but hopefully now
on the up and up and of course we've got
a monitor for complications and
sometimes after when you have various
tubes inside of you for a week when they
remove the tubes
you've got to watch what happens and
you've got to watch for infection and
all these different things so we're not
completely out of the woods yet but it's
so great to have a little bit of a sense
of normality and to be back on the show
today but that was last week it was not
really paternity leave in a sense it was
in that it was connected to the birth
and uh interestingly that this was
the the ob team
that was part of everything even though
this was not an ob related uh procedure
the ob team was was involved in
everything they said
our entire practice is now changing how
we do
uh postpartum advil we used to do it
what's called prn the patient just
requests it when they feel they need it
and then they often wouldn't and then
they'd wake up and they'd be in pain so
we would uh just just do it uh every six
hours and we're not gonna do that
anymore so crazy situation
good to be back let's talk now about the
outlook for 2022
one of the
conventional wisdoms in terms of
democrats running in midterms and in
presidential elections one of the
conventional wisdoms is you run on the
economy mostly
sometimes uh there are other issues that
that have a big impact but you mostly
run on the economy and in general it's
believed and i believe the polling
normally bears this out to be true
running on gun safety isn't good for
democrats in national elections and
running on abortion isn't good for
democrats in national elections and
historically i believe that that's been
true and we've seen polling to that
effect and we've talked to experts who
say these are not when democrats run on
gun safety it doesn't really motivate
other democrats to get out and vote and
it often will motivate republicans to
come out and vote against those
democrats the polling this election
cycle now in the aftermath of roe v wade
being overturned by the supreme court
and in the aftermath of republicans
willing to do very very little if
anything when it comes to gun safety
okay it looks like there's going to be
this kind of very small bill but it's
not really going to deal with the major
issues along
gun safety it actually may be exactly
what democrats should run on for the
midterms if the attention span of the
electorate is still going to keep those
issues in the forefront of voters minds
in november
which is four and a half months from now
so let's look at the polling first and
we have two sets of polling here first
of all we have a new cbs news poll
americans react to the overturning of
roe v wade most disapprove most call it
a step backward and
when you look at the data
um among all americans only 41 percent
approve of the supreme court overturning
roe v wade and 59
disapprove and when you look at women
specifically it is even more skewed only
a third of women approve of the supreme
court overturning roe v wade and
two-thirds of women disapprove now this
shouldn't surprise us in the sense that
we've been tracking public attitudes
towards abortion since roe v wade and
support for abortion being legal in most
cases has increased ev over the last 50
years every time the poll is done
support for roe v wade support for
abortion being legal in most cases has
gone up
so that's not a surprise also from the
poll 52 percent of americans believe
that overturning roe v wade is a step
backwards
whereas only 31 believe that overturning
roe v wade is a step forward 17 believe
that it is neither uh without question
the world looks at the united states
overturning roe v wade what we have seen
i mean look at my country of argentina
which was very much behind on abortion
rights in the last i don't remember it
it feels like it's been the last five
years in the last five years going in
the direction of legalizing abortion
most countries go in the direction of
legalizing the united states now going
backwards and this is what conservatives
talk about when they say conserve they
don't even mean conserve the status quo
they mean go back to the 1950s or even
beyond in certain cases so not not a
surprise there
and then um what will the impact of roe
v wade being overturned beyond women's
lives
56 percent of americans believe that
this will make women's lives worse
while only 16 percent believe that
overturning roe v wade will make women's
lives better and then lastly on the
question of will they go further
57 percent of americans believe it is
likely that that next the supreme court
will try to limit same-sex marriage and
55 percent of americans believe that the
supreme court will next or soon try to
limit access to birth control something
that i have been talking about
extensively with many of you for a long
time so
that to me signals
this time around
running on they're taking our rights
they're taking abortion as a right
and they want to come for same-sex
marriage i mean clarence thomas wrote it
in his opinion that may actually be a
good idea these midterms second issue is
gun safety and we've looked at some of
these numbers before americans
overwhelmingly support
the vast majority of gun safety
regulations that have been proposed
there's some pew research data which vox
summarized into a very good graphic
which i have on this on the screen now
and let's see if i can zoom it in a
little bit there
when you ask about what about mental
health restrictions on firearms um
close to 90 percent of americans the
black dot here is the overall um close
to 90 percent of americans support that
more than 80 percent of americans
support
81 support background checks on every
purchase no gun purchases that would be
exempt 79 of americans support uh rather
oppose concealed carry without a permit
there are states where you don't need a
permit to concealed carry you can just
do it
um
almost 80 of americans are against that
a 77 support family initiated red flag
laws where a family could say hey this
person is not stable they should not be
able to uh have firearms 70 support
police-initiated red flag laws and even
these provisions that have lower support
still have nearly two-thirds support
bans on high-capacity magazines 64
percent and bans on assault style
weapons 63 percent so i believe at this
point it is completely clear these are
good issues for democrats to run on this
time around what are the counterpoints
well the counterpoints are democrats
haven't been particularly strong on a
lot of these issues either in terms of
what they've been able to accomplish now
you can then say well but that's because
of republican obstructionism sure sure
but is there credibility in democrats
saying we're going to take care of these
issues we're going to get back to that
issue a little bit later in the show
another counterpoint these issues seem
very
one-sided and important and relevant
today to voters but what about on
november 8th we've got four and a half
months of
pumping up on right-wing media oh fuel
prices and inflation and the border and
ukraine and these issues that are used
to attack joe biden even if they have
very little to do with joe biden
will guns and abortions still be on the
minds of voters come november 8th how
long is the understandable outrage about
roe v wade
and gun safety going to last and then
and then lastly and this is what we'll
get back to when we look at some viral
uh a viral interview clip a little bit
later
are there enough voters who see
democrats
as credible on these issues to say okay
i'm outraged about what happened
but do i believe that voting for
democrats is the way that we're going to
improve the situation we'll talk about
that a little bit later but in the
immediate let me know you can find me on
twitter at deepakman
do you believe
that guns and abortion
in this particular election cycle are
good issues for democrats to run on let
me know find me on twitter at dpakman
and we'll keep talking about it after
the break many people are shocked when
their identity is stolen but it's
actually one of the fastest growing
crimes in the u.s i've dealt with it
it's a terrible feeling and that's why i
now protect myself with aura one of our
sponsors aura monitors email addresses
passwords social security number bank
accounts credit cards and i can set it
up to instantly get an alert on my phone
if something happens and then aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
or also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name or it takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below
the primary funding source of the david
pakman show is your support through our
membership program i invite you to sign
up at joinpacman.com grab yourselves a
membership we do an extra show every
single day for our paid members it's
called the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad well thank you alex many people
enjoy the bonus show daily and so i
would not listen to alex jones on that
you can sign up at joinpakman.com and
use the coupon code big voting 22 big
voting 22
to get yourself a healthy discount off
of the cost of a membership there is a
video going viral of pro-choice
activists crushing
yes the democratic party
over immediate opportunistic fundraising
attempts saying oh the supreme court
overturned roe v wade rush us money give
us money so that we can fix this and
we're going to look at that video now i
am thrilled that this is getting
attention in fact
i tweeted about the vile nature of both
sides immediately fundraising off of the
supreme court decision last week i
tweeted quote is there anyone not
raising money off of today's supreme
court decision fundraising emails off
the charts right-wingers saying now is
the time to keep going give us money
left-wingers saying give us money to fix
this and i didn't find either of those
uh
particularly good faith uh rather
finding it completely opportunistic so
let's check out this video which has
gone completely viral this this is zoe
warren and julianne dioretta of rise up
for abortion they spoke to msnbc
and they beautifully point out the
absurdity now
of
democrats and yes republicans as well
the republicans as well don't get me
wrong of democrats immediately saying
give us cash so that we can fix this
when we know why this happened and part
of it has to do
with democrats and of course much of it
has to do with the fact that
we when we you start the sequence of
events
it's donald trump won in 2016 and then
appointed supreme court justices and
then it was the exact playbook
republicans started challenging abortion
at the state level with the goal of
appealing it to the supreme court with
the goal of getting the supreme court to
overturn roe v wade we we predicted it
in 2016 and that's exactly what happened
let's check out this video um
absolutely fascinating and well said so
i received a text message from joe
biden's campaign yesterday saying that
the supreme court had overturned rope
versus wade and that it was my
responsibility to then rush 15 to the
democratic national party um and i
thought that was absolutely outrageous
because my rights should not be a fun
fundraising point for them
or a campaigning point
they have had multiple opportunities to
codify row into law over the past 20 30
40 50 years and they haven't done it and
if they're going to keep campaigning on
this point they should actually do
something about it what are you most
worried about
i'm most worried about what comes next
because roe versus wade was a president
for oberval vs hodges loving versus
virginia irving versus texas gay
marriage interracial marriage and
privacy in the bedroom correct and those
as clarence thomas came out yesterday
they're going to be falling like
dominoes um you come from texas you're
in austin texas there's a trailer law in
place in austin in 30 days yeah
abortion's gonna be abandoned your state
abortion has been banned at six weeks in
my state since last september which is
an essential all-out ban because most
women don't even realize they're
pregnant before that point and there
when there are women in texas who've
already died and have already been
arrested for having an abortion or a
miscarriage because we can't really tell
that it seems like you have obvious
anger towards the democratic party
because you feel as if they've missed
chances to codify roe up until this
point and then here we are what does
that mean for you when it comes to
midterm elections and getting more
democrats um elected to move forward
with trying to codify um rowe well when
it comes down to the primaries which i
think are coming up in the next couple
months
it means that we need to get as many
people to the polls as possible to vote
for more progressive democrats we need
to get the old white democrats out of
office and put in new younger people who
will actually defend the rights of women
and people all over this country and
then when it comes to midterms we need
to make sure that we have those same
people who voted for the progressive
people in the primaries coming back to
the midterms and voting again and making
sure that these more progressive
democrats get into office and connect so
she's absolutely right i don't tend to
do the identity politics stuff in terms
of saying we need to get white democrats
out i want a diversity of representation
that that that's me okay so don't
ascribe saying get white people out to
me that's not the way i would i would
use that term but
this is completely spot on in the sense
that both parties have used abortion
rights
as a divisive fundraising issue for
decades i happen to agree
with the political position of the
democrats as an individual because i'm
pro-choice but this has been an issue
that's been a fundraising issue on both
sides for decades
in some sense
i recognized and i knew
that democrats i'm sorry that
republicans benefit from roe v wade in
the sense that it's something they can
keep fundraising on as long as roe v
wade is there
republicans can say give us money to
oppose roe v wade now they've gotten roe
v wade overturned so some have been
emailing and saying well now now how are
republicans going to raise money well
they're going to be fine now they're
going to say let's push for a federal
ban on abortion that would be the next
step now they've eliminated roe v wade
which kind of uh enshrines abortion as
as a right but the next step would be
well let's let's get a ban on it and at
the state level they can work on bans
they can start working on blue states
right even if it's unlikely to succeed
they can say give us money so we can get
abortion banned in california and in
connecticut and in new york and
massachusetts and maryland or whatever
else so they're still going to have ways
to fundraise and the crazy thing is
the republican continued fundraising on
this issue is is going to be more
credible feeling in a sense
because when you look at the democratic
party
the protesters here are correct
there have been so many missed
opportunities to codify roe v wade and
abortion rights and to do so many other
things so
while
you can pick the side that matches your
political position and say well i'll
give the money
the republicans now have actually
accomplished something major they they
have gotten roe v wade overturned and so
their fundraising on this issue is
almost more credible than that which
we're seeing by democrats and i got
those fundraising emails as well if
there was something pathetic about it
there was something disgusting about it
saying they overturned roe v wade send
us 15 now fifteen dollars to do what
exactly
particularly when uh we we need people
in the democratic party in elected power
uh who are gonna fight much harder for
it so very interesting very interesting
viral viral um interview there and uh
we'll continue covering that
there was a completely bizarre dystopian
rally over the weekend in illinois this
was a rally in support supposedly of
illinois republican mary miller now mary
miller once praised adolf hitler we'll
get to that
donald trump spoke at this rally donald
trump was completely incoherent he
looked disoriented he struggled to speak
even in repeating some of the same lines
we've become used to ad nauseam from
trump he was visibly struggling to
deliver them so first i'll give you a
reminder
mary miller the rally was in support of
mary miller here is older footage of
mary miller who said hey you know hitler
was right about one thing
each generation has the responsibility
to teach
in the next generation you know if we
win a few elections we're still going to
be losing unless we win the hearts
of our children this it's the battle
hitler was right on one thing he said
whoever has a youth has the future
our children are being propagandized
yeah and you know if you want to make
the case that the youngest generation is
going to decide what the future looks
like you can find people other than
hitler who have made similar points so
choosing to quote hitler and say that
this is this hitler knew this pretty
wacky stuff so this is who trump went to
illinois to support that's who he was
there to support
maybe the most bizarre moment of trump's
speech trump mimicking weightlifting
during the
anti-transgender part of the rally
there's always an anti-trans part of the
rally now
there you go so that's trump uh
yeah
um this is now a regular part of every
rally trump saying teachers should not
be allowed to teach transgender
very strange grammatical syntax
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children for
that one guarantee
never ever teach transgender to our
children
um
i don't know exactly what he means
teachers shouldn't be allowed to
mention that trans people exist what
does that even really mean
but completely mushmouth and unable to
deliver these uh these diatribes um at a
certain point trump endorsed this is so
funny endorsed mary miller
i don't know that i've ever heard a less
enthusiastic endorsement he's sort of
like yeah you know vote for her she'll
be good go out and vote for mary you'll
never be disappointed with mary she
doesn't disappoint
people and she loves you very much yeah
you can really tell trump is viscerally
committed to supporting uh mary miller
there yeah yeah yeah go and go and vote
for her and then donald trump is now
claiming that the january 6 trump riot
committee
is using doctored video doctored video
to make their points now i have to tell
you
if the argument you're relegated to is
the videos were doctored
the testimony was probably pretty damn
effective take a look at this
to this day the leaders of the democrat
party have failed to forcefully condemn
the violence and threats and hold
the perpetrators accountable
there could be no greater illustration
of the two-tiered system of justice
we've never had anything like what's
going on right now
that we have in our country than the
fact that
at the very moment the radical democrats
were staging a ridiculous fake trial
over january 6. their party leaders are
saying nothing about the violent
intimidation of the united states
supreme court they refused to talk about
it they refused to do anything
as you have seen the vile group of
unhinged partisans and craven lunatics
on the unselect committee are pushing a
fake and fabricated narrative based on
doctored video lies and tests by the way
i hate to interrupt but just the toe so
trump is lying to the crowd
there are the blacks for trump people
are up on the stage strategically placed
behind trump
and the channel broadcasting the speech
right side broadcasting is offering a
free gold coin if you text trump
it's i mean it's gripped upon lie upon
grift upon lie testimony that is totally
uncontested by cross-examination the
lies are unbelievable
it's a disgrace to our country
a bunch of rhinos get up they're going
to make their name big for a day
everything they're showing is ripped
utterly out of context such as when liz
cheney a real loser she is cut out
cut out the part of my quote in a speech
that i made a certain speech
that said
that their voices should be heard
peacefully and patriotically she left
those words out would you say that's
nice she left them out
it's a sham think of that she left out
the words peacefully and patriotically
why aren't they investigating massive
election fraud and irregularities
instead of investigating because it
doesn't exist the people who want to get
to the bottom of a rigged and stolen
election
all right
so you get the point there and there
seems to be a growing sensation within
trumpland
that the hearings were much more
effective than they imagined they would
be and this is why they're now relegated
to saying the video is doctored the
video is doctored that's what it is
the uh news story from trump and it's
not new but trump is now regularly
talking about it is
nancy pelosi
allowed the riots to get out of control
trump has said this a few times before
but now he's really piling on
and why didn't nancy pelosi and the
mayor of washington dc
accept my offer on january third three
days before
of 10 000 soldiers or national guard or
more
to protect the capital you know they are
in charge of security now that is untrue
this has been repeated many times it's
not true first of all there's no
evidence trump made any request to
deploy ten thousand national guard
troops before the rally trump it's been
claimed there's no evidence of that
whatsoever number one secondly nancy
pelosi is not in charge the capitol
police are in charge the capitol police
are overseen by the capitol police board
and committees from the senate and from
the house it is not nancy pelosi that is
in charge so that's a lie
trump also taking the opportunity to
mention that you should sign up for his
um platform truth social truth essential
yeah and saying there's no free speech
anymore but sign up for truth we don't
have
free speech in america yeah
go out and sign up now for truth social
who's on truth social
doing good very muted response there um
truth social will ban you if you post
clips from the january 6th committee
hearing so not exactly the unfettered
bastion of free speech that donald trump
claims it to be and then lastly not very
patriotic trump saying america is no
longer a great nation these illinois
heroes poor are
incredible they just went out and they
poured
their heart and soul to make america
into the greatest nation in the history
of the world they worked to make america
the greatest nation
in the history of the world
but
it is no longer a great nation
it is a nation
in decline
wow
no longer a great nation and of course i
thought the patriots always would say
america is always great it's always the
best i guess now maybe
an s whole country might be better i
guess because joe biden is president so
everything going wrong trump completely
incoherent and supporting someone
with no enthusiasm whatsoever
who once explained that hitler was right
about one thing that is the modern state
of trumpism and the crowd just eats it
all up he could tell him anything and
they would clap and they would cheer
we'll have these clips on our instagram
you can find them at david pakman show
we'll take a break after the break
we're going to hear from some trump
supporters at the rally and my
recommendation would be get the children
out of the room
all right let's take a little tour
through the mind of magga donald trump
holding this rally for mary miller in
mendon illinois over the weekend we
looked at some of the things donald
trump had to say we talked a little bit
about
things mary miller has said let's now
look at the attendees
and i continue to think that there's a
bit of a split between sort of like your
normal republicans with whom i still
disagree on policy but they're basically
people who like on a weekend
they might
you know
go to a tag sale or take their kids to
soccer or maybe you know even go to a
shooting range or whatever that there's
those republicans and then there's the
republicans that are willing to travel
to a trump rally and these are very
different people i'm not saying i love
the normal republicans political views
that's not what i'm saying but but there
is a distinction here and we're going to
start with a guy
who um
you know what i'm not even we're just
going to start with a guy okay let's
listen to what he had to say florida is
an old neurotoxin that's used to kill
rats
and the nazis used to put it with uh
stalin they'd had a 1936 world court
stop it right there then why hasn't
we've seen a lot of people drop dead
like rats that's a great question why
hasn't we've seen that's exactly the
question i would ask from brushing their
teeth with fluoride or using it see if
you give a low toxic dose see if you had
a massive dose of forehead you would die
now in your tube of toothpaste it does
say contact the emergency room if you
swallow a p drop size it actually has
that warning on the tube of toothpaste
and there are thousands of visits every
year for over fluoridation toothpaste
but that's a minor issue putting it in
the water oh god do you know that that
extrapolated study for fluoride safety
was very simply done with topical
fluoride on a tooth in a laboratory
ingesting fluid was never studied kind
of like the sm-102 of the ingredient of
the vaccine okay so let's stop you right
there because i've got a lot of people
right now that are going wait a minute
he just said that if i swallow
toothpaste you have to go the emergency
you're going to go to the emergency room
okay
now normally it says
if more than is used for brushing is
swallowed like i know it doesn't even
matter you and you know and i know that
this is the you this these are
completely closed forms of thinking but
what it actually says is if more than is
used for brushing but put that aside
stupid toothpaste it says it on the box
okay so uh okay flow right aside let's
push that aside
tell me how you got let me check mercury
we'll push that aside too let's push all
chemicals on the chemical table to the
side real quickly how expert on
chemicals and biological warfare let's
not talk about that right now i want to
talk about how you got 15 million
democrats to vote for president trump oh
on a handshake and my reputation of
being the holistic uh guru of the world
you're shaking 15 million hands
so obviously that's very significant
mental illness and it's treated as
normal it's treated as political
discourse it's treated as
these are the constituents of a
political movement and we don't want to
stigmatize mental illness it's not about
making fun of it but it is important to
point out when you have a political
contingent that whose origins are a
complete disconnect from the real world
so when we talk about you know there's
gradations of this there's gradations
the comet ping pong stuff
that was that was heavily influenced by
complete paranoid delusions being
suffered by many of the people who were
promulgating that that stuff and it's
all gradations thinking taxes should be
lower
is not this this is on one end right
thinking we should have a lower tax rate
is on the other and in the middle
there's a whole bunch of different stuff
and much of it has just become accepted
as valid political discourse very very
crazy stuff here's one woman who was
asked what are trump's biggest
accomplishments this is a big trump fan
it's funny that she even struggles to
explain what they are on ground here
favorite thing that president trump did
while he was in office was what yeah
oh gosh
helping the military
um
military seems to be a very popular
subject i love how the interviewer is
like there you go it's almost like
dealing with someone who
can't think
and then they come up with something you
know like can you tell us what
what year is it well it's um
[Music]
it's 20
20
two yeah twenty twenty two good there
you go i mean he's he's treating her
like she's an invalid
uh but the point here is they don't even
know why they like trump yeah and
allowing more prayer yeah allowing more
prayer and helping the military are the
big accomplishments of trump here is a
gentleman who claims to be former law
enforcement who his big thing is uh gun
rights i'm just going to tell you i'm a
retired law enforcement hey i'm i'm a
lifetime member of the nra yeah i'm all
about the second amendment i feel safe
standing right next to you i'll tell you
that he's my next guest hey i'm all
about that i'm all about the second
amendment and what do you
you know there's a special snowflake
feel to a lot of these trump supporters
and let me explain what i mean by that
um one of the things i've talked about
before
is that to some degree
this entire
narrative
that exists
it's characterized as being more on the
left of everyone is special
and everyone is you know what whatever
that
sometimes taken too far it can sort of
create problems of self-centeredness and
um
etc where like yes we're all individuals
we all bring unique perspectives to the
table everyone deserves to have their
ideas uh uh heard and children should be
celebrated oh that's all that's all true
but at the same time we're all one of
eight billion people
and uh everybody has to kind of be part
of the collective and there's millions
of people that fall into every category
and we sort of like need some balance
when you go too far
one of the things that i get the feeling
of with some of these folks
is they believe that they they are
completely
unique and above everything else the law
enforcement guy listen
i'm retired law enforcement and the
second amendment and this makes me
unique in my support for trump and how i
should be listened to it this is the
thing they criticize about the left they
go oh all these leftist special
snowflake well they kind of do the same
thing as a teacher who supports assault
rifles
i am here and i know that it is trump
that we need okay all right it's just
another opinion among hundreds of
millions like let's let's apply
some healthy skepticism to everyone's uh
perspective here to some degree okay
then we go to the next guy
um
this guy doesn't know what's going on i
won't even introduce this when they when
the left media went berserk over
president trump drinking with two hands
or walking slow down an icy step i mean
this guy's fallen up the stairs to
airplane water airplane won
three times and and where putin is out
uh ice skating and riding horses
and practicing their foreign affairs
which are really poor right now but
with the weak leader the rest all right
so anyway putin's strong and trump is
strong
but biden is weak that seems to be the
most important perspective and then
here's another woman asked about again
about trump's biggest accomplishment in
office and she struggles to these these
folks are struggling favorite thing that
trump did during uh his tenure in the
white house was what just one thing
i'm putting you on the spot for just one
i'm sure there's i mean i feel like he
really brought our country together for
once i mean i can't think of a president
at least in my lifetime that's brought
us together as a whole like that yeah
remember how united the country was
under trump that's uh that that's that's
pretty pretty interesting so
sometimes i wonder how these folks even
manage to feed themselves and many of
them raise kids i mean that's that's the
that's the incredible thing
but uh a very interesting and different
political constituency and the question
will be without trump on the ballot in
november do they vote with trump gone
from the white house and not on the
ballot do they vote and do trumpian
candidates win in november
four and a half months and we'll have
that answer
last bit of uh commentary from trump's
rally in mendon illinois a mike pillow
the ceo of my pillow mike lindell known
to us as pillow of course we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines he
spoke and the crowd essentially
slept through him saying cnn is no
longer calling it the big lie
because it's all true
that the election was stolen from trump
in 2020. the crowd's totally bored by it
cnn gets up getting out in front of him
and they said we were no longer call it
the big lie
because they know it was the big truth
and the big lie was the big lie right
donald trump won that election 81 or 82
million to biden 66 million those are
the real totals everybody yeah trump
really won by what is that 14 16 16
million votes um this is a lie that
they're repeating that cnn no longer
calls it the big lie
because it's true that the election was
stolen from trump all that happened is
that there's been a shakeup in cnn
management and they've decided they want
to get away from the term the big lie
that nothing is changing about
the truth or in this case the falsity of
the claim that joe biden stole the
election from trump they've made an
editorial decision not to call it the
big lie nothing else has changed and
also a major major major announcement
from mike pillow he is now launching my
coffee but there's something funny about
it which doesn't sound very patriotic to
me take a listen to this but i'm
actually going to miami in three three
days
or four days for filming
for filming filming we have my coffee
this is a family owned coffee it's the
best coffee you're ever gonna have in
your life
there's nothing like it i and believe me
everything that i put out there i do my
due diligence right i mean it's just
been six months in the work
works these guys have their own fields
in colombia
whoa wait a second they're in colombia
now i know many of you will say but hold
on a second david sir
most coffee beans are grown outside of
the united states for climate reasons
the united states is just not suited
climactically climatically climb i think
it's climactically to growing coffee
beans well okay but hawaii is
why isn't pillow doing the patriotic
thing and saying we will get
u.s raised coffee beans from hawaii no
he's offshoring it to colombia family
owned they've been doing it
imagine imagine a micro remember like a
microphone you know you could grind your
own or you can have you know a micron
field what the hell it's already ground
but having that where you can get it for
prices because that's what i do bring
the best to you right well it sounds
like the best isn't american mike uh
what what a situation and this guy will
not go away it's actually interesting
that he's not fading at all and uh i
don't know what to make of it but the
crowd increasingly bored by mike pillow
we'll take a quick break back after this
we are going to hear some reactions
including from christy gnome governor of
south dakota to a great question okay so
you ban abortion
who funds all these children that women
are forced to carry the term she did not
have a good answer we'll look at it
after the break
one of the big questions of course in
the in the aftermath of the supreme
court overturning roe v wade is great
you'll force all these women to have
children that they don't want or don't
feel equipped or don't have the money to
have
who is going to help the women who's
going to pay for the kids because it's
not very pro-life
to force a birth and then do nothing for
the mother or the child in that
situation and in fact i tweeted about
this uh sort of tongue-in-cheek by
saying now that roe v wade and i know
that i've misspelled roe the the voice
to text misspelled that i i throw myself
at your mercy now that roe v wade has
been overturned the right wing will show
their devotion to children by expanding
the child tax credit funding child care
and pre-k paid maternity and paternity
leave etc i can't wait for them to do it
and of course it's tongue-in-cheek
because they don't plan to do that well
trump suckup republican governor of
south dakota christie gnome was
interviewed over the weekend by martha
raddatz
and she was asked what are you going to
do for these women you said they will
never be alone what exactly does that
mean her answer leaves a little bit to
be desired but we want to help support
these mothers i think we can do better
in this country making sure that we're
walking alongside them in these
situations and making sure that they do
have the type of health care and the
support financially that they need
we'll look let's look at that support
the nonpartisan commonwealth fund a
social policy think tank
says the 14 states that have the most
restrictive abortion laws including
south dakota invest the least in
policies and programs for women and
children so right
what do you mean when you say these
mothers will never be alone yes
well i would say that the facts on the
ground are that south dakota is doing a
lot to coordinate with nonprofits with
churches and then also the state in a
new way by launching this website and
committing to in legislative session to
support these mothers is incredibly
powerful you know this is a conversation
that okay so so far she said we're going
to help support women
we're going to walk alongside women we
are doing a lot with churches
and we are going to um oh and
non-profits as well and they're going to
really talk about this in legislative
session wow well it sounds like it's
going to be fine doesn't it we have a
change now at the federal level the
states will be each evaluating how they
approach this situation right getting
health care to mothers helping them
during a time of crisis is incredibly
important and these states remember
martha are overwhelmed right now with
other situations that are going on with
what joe biden is doing to the energy
prices in this guys how can you expect
south
south dakota to help the women forced to
birth a child
when there's an energy crisis created by
joe biden yeah i mean south dakota has
to deal with that they can't help the
women um and then here's another uh oh
and this is also interesting um
even though
christy gnome says a bunch of times that
women shouldn't be prosecuted for
getting an abortion
she leaves open the door
to prosecuting women who leave the state
to get an abortion and then come back
listen to this
and just one more question what if your
constituents travel to another state to
get an abortion right
you know that certainly isn't addressed
in our statute today and so it's not
addressed
in our statute today
okay that's not a statement of opinion
though that's just what it is right now
i think that's things that they'll be
debate about there will oh there will be
debate about what to do about that wow
but also we're having lots of debates in
south dakota how fundamentally our life
has changed the last couple of years
just with increased costs and inflation
and what this administration is doing to
every single family's budget so
understand she is not saying oh martha
no no no if someone goes to another
state where abortion is legal and then
comes back
obviously we're not going to do anything
about that that's not the way the law
works that's not the way states work no
no she actually deflects and then talks
about joe biden in energy prices
she's leaving the door open just saying
we will actually try
to prosecute women who leave
go to a state where abortion's legal
have an abortion and then come back
they're going to try i'm not saying they
will succeed
but they're going to try hey this is
very very strange there is a new report
that radical trumpist republican
congressman matt gates under
investigation for a number of different
potential crimes including trafficking
of a minor across state lines for sexual
purposes
we have a report now that matt gates
sought a trump pardon
before
the trump riots
this is um this is strange because it
raises the question of why did he want
that pardon newsweek report says
florida republican congressman matt
gates
had been personally pushing for a broad
presidential pardon from donald trump
before and after the january sixth
attack the house committee investigating
the riot revealed one of the biggest
revelations from thursday's hearing was
the testimony naming six republicans
including gates and others who wanted
clemency from trump before he left
office by the way that includes louis
gomert and marjorie taylor greene
additionally alabama representative mo
brooks allegedly allegedly sent an email
on january 11 seeking quote all-purpose
pardons for every lawmaker who objected
to electoral votes from arizona and
pennsylvania
gates has been contacted for comment
the other gates part in her recorded
testimony it was described how gates had
been asking for a presidential pardon
before the other republican lawmakers
accused of being involved in attempts to
overturn the 2020 election quote gates
was personally pushing for a pardon and
he was doing so since early december i'm
not sure why said hutchinson he reached
out to me to ask if he could have a
meeting with meadows about receiving a
presidential pardon eric hershman a
trump white house lawyer also said in
testimony played on thursday gates
wanted a wide reaching pardon from trump
quote the general tone was we may get
prosecuted because we were defensive of
the president's position on these things
the pardon he was discussing requesting
was as broad as you could describe from
the beginning of time up until today for
any and all things he mentioned nixon
and i said nixon's pardon was never
nearly that broad
this is very strange so the natural
question is why did matt gates so early
and so broadly
want a pre-emptive blanket pardon
the natural speculation is was gates
trying to crowbar in a pre-emptive
pardon
for the things he's being investigated
for personally well it's merely
speculation
but it's a reasonable question to ask
the issue is most of the stuff let me
i'll put it a different way
many of the things gates is being
investigated for are state crimes and
not federal crimes and a presidential
pardon wouldn't help you with state
crimes that being said the interstate
trafficking of minors that's a federal
crime and that's a really big deal so
one speculation is gates figured you
know everybody's going to try to get
pardons and we're going to say it's for
supporting trump's view about the
election and trying to fix it and all
these different things but maybe i can
sneak in some help with what i may be up
against criminally
for my personal activities that's one
possibility it is amazing that we
regularly are
charging regularly and quickly charging
all sorts of different people poor
people non-white people people not in
positions of power for insignificant
oftentimes kind of contrived charges the
war on drugs you could argue is
contrived at the big picture
uh as we know the origins of it to be a
sort of racist reaction to the civil
rights act of the 1960s
and then meanwhile gates
and his fellow whatever
can be suspected of having committed
pretty serious crimes
and they just walk around they often
never even get charged and when they do
it's all done very respectfully to their
image and to their pr
um even when there is in the case of
gates corroborating witnesses
corroborating witnesses who are
cooperating as we know jared
greenberg i think is the guy's name and
the example of gates so you know trump
likes to talk about two justice systems
the one for right wingers and the one
for everybody else it's a completely
bogus framing of the entire issue we do
have two justice systems in the united
states i've talked about it for a long
time it's people in positions of power
and who have money and who have
influence and then everybody else and uh
we are definitely seeing that with trump
and his cronies and the people around
him and maybe also with matt gates the
reason for gates wanting this
pre-emptive blanket pardon
we can speculate maybe at some point we
will know but it's a real question mark
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p this is a new
favorite caller of mine this is one of
the most confident callers i've ever had
this caller says he is the authority on
ufos and aliens and he is going to now
beyond any doubt tell us the truth the
truth about ufos listen to this
yeah david great show i don't watch too
often i'm too busy but i have another
follow-up comment about ufos
loves the show never watches it that's
okay i'll take the praise uh you could
bank on this and i am good when i do my
research i consider myself the best i
already have a proven track record
the evolution of our solar system before
the earth was formed and all the planet
has never repeat has never been visited
by probes or
observations from any repeat any
extraterrestrial society
in the entire universe or from
these
baloney
theories about multi-universes or
fourth-dimensional b
never
there had never been a ufo that landed
on this planet no probes no pass by
nothing
there's no aliens living on this planet
okay all right i think i think you get
it i really appreciate the caller
confidently putting that to rest and i
know there are people in our audience
with different perspectives on this
issue but this call
if you go by his confidence he must be
completely correct we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today sarah huckabee
sanders says that if she is governor
kids in the womb will be as safe as kids
in classrooms
wait a second that something about that
is not making sense we will discuss it
we have a study that finds that when a
state passes a concealed carry law gun
crime goes up by 33 percent and we will
also talk about the belief among more
than half of americans that the supreme
court is coming for gay marriage sooner
or later after the roe v wade decision
that the supreme court is coming for gay
marriage i happen to agree
and we will talk about that on today's
bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com you will get instant
access to the bonus show that is a
freaking predator right now not
predatory at all if you like it then you
keep it that's how it is use the coupon
code bigvoting22
to sign up at joinpakman.com get instant
access to the bonus show
and then if all goes well i will be back
here with you tomorrow
i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below